hello learners welcome to this new video
by simply learn search engine
optimization or seo has proven to be one
of the most important factors in getting
higher rankings in the search results
seo strategies like image optimization
page optimization
backlink building keyword research etc
are responsible for getting higher
rankings in search results however
keyword research has its own importance
in both the ways
that is for organic search as well as
for the paid search thereby
becoming an important part of search
engine optimization
in this video we are going to put a
light
and learn in depth about keyword
research for search engine optimization
but before we begin
please consider subscribing to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss any updates from simply learn
now let's have an overview of what we
are going to learn in this video
first let's understand what do we mean
by keyword research
next we will know about the importance
of keyword research
before going in depth about the topic it
is necessary to know what is long tail
keywords and short tail keywords
moving ahead we will check the list of
keyword research tools
further we will understand how to
perform keyword research
next we will understand how to do
keyword research with the help of
various tools
next we will see how keyword research is
important in grabbing the job
opportunities
where we are going to cover all the
roles and responsibilities
and finally we will end this discussion
by knowing the scope of keyword research
in the coming years
dear learners if you want to get
certified as a skilled seo professional
that too for free
do have a look at the advanced search
engine optimization skill up course by
simply learn
check the link in the description box
below
so let's begin this interesting session
by knowing what keyword research is
yes we are definitely going to know what
is keyword research but before this it
is important to understand
what is a keyword
keywords are the ideas or topics that
clearly describe what your content is
about
say for example here the title of the
slide is what is keyword research
so this is the keyword which suggests
that
this slide contains the content about
keyword research
so basically
keyword research
is a process of identifying keywords or
popular search terms that people tends
to search for
when you identify relevant keywords
all you need to do is
include these keywords smartly into your
content
and this will help your content to get
higher rankings and search results now
the question arises
why does keyword research has so much of
importance and search engine
optimization
let's understand this
keyword research plays a major role in
driving traffic organically to your
website or your content
but how does this exactly happens
when you select the most appropriate
keyword for your content
there is an opportunity
where you can rank high in search
results by ranking higher there are more
chances that audience can discover your
content and reach to your website
thus you get more and more consistent
traffic growth for your website
thereby indirectly promoting your
products and services
now that you are aware
of how keyword research holds importance
let's now see some essential types of
keywords
that is
long tail keywords and short tail
keywords so first we will start with
long tail keywords
long tail keywords are the keywords that
are mostly used to get more specific
results
long tail keywords include keywords with
three or more words
for example
shoes for a black dress
now coming to short tail keywords
short tail keywords are the general
keywords or more specifically general
search terms short tail keywords include
one or two words in the keyword
for example shoes
now let's see the difference between
both the long tail and short tail
keywords by demonstrating let's go to
google.com
so now we are here
to check the difference between long
tail keywords and short tail keywords
so first we will check for the short
tail keyword
now suppose i am looking for the shoes
that should go perfectly with my
beautiful black dress
so here i add
shoes
and see how the results are appearing
okay if you see the recommendations here
we get shoes for men shoes for women
shoes images
shoe size chart
shoes for rainy season
etc etc
and if i enter here
on the shoes
what are the results here i get number
of results from the shopping websites
with the very number of shoes
with number of brands and somewhere
locations of the shops
but none of the result is relevant
to
what i am expecting that is the shoes
for my black dress
okay so now
i'll just change
my search query
i'll add a long tail keyword here
and i will search here more specifically
for what i wanted
so here i'll add
shoes for
black
dress
okay
so here i am getting number of ideas the
image ideas in the search result that
what kind of shoes are going to go best
with my black dress
and
here i'm getting several combinations
which i can wear with my black dress
so 12 best color shoes
here again i'm getting
if you observe clearly then all these
results are completely aligned to what
exactly i am looking for
okay
and if i again change this query
more specific like shoes for black dress
for
woman
let's see what i get
so here i am getting more specific
results
in terms of women's
we will definitely understand how to use
long tail keywords or short tail
keywords during our research in the
upcoming part of this video let's now
have a look on tools required for
carrying out keyword research
here i have got a small list of tools
that you will need to perform effective
keyword research
so first we will begin with keyword
planner
keyword planner
is a free keyword research tool provided
by google some of the important features
of keyword planner includes discovery of
new keywords
estimate monthly searches for a keyword
get the average cost of ads for the
keyword you are looking for
and help to organize keywords the next
tool that we have in our bucket is sem
rush
some important features of sem rush
includes
helps to get competitor keywords data
it helps to get competitor backlinks
data
finds competitors top performing content
helps in getting competitors campaign
data etc
let me bring it to your notice that sem
rush is one of the best platforms that
fulfill all your seo needs
so do visit to
semrush.com you can find the link in the
description box below
next tool that we have in our bucket is
rfs the free keyword generator tool by
rfs helps to discovered keyword ideas
helps in identifying the search volume
estimations
identify easy keywords for which you can
possibly rank for
helps you to get a list of long tail
keywords
and however it is not limited to google
searches only yes you heard it right
you can get keyword ideas for google
bing
youtube
yahoo etc
now let's check another tool which is
google trends
google trend will come into action
during your keyword research when you're
looking for the top search queries by
users
that is the most trending queries
moreover you can check these details of
search queries
for your country for any other country
or even worldwide not only this but you
can also choose a type of search for
this query like web search email search
youtube search etc
the next tool that we have is answer the
public tool
answer the public tool has free as well
as paid versions
this tool can prove a magic wand for
your business as it suggests the
questions that are asked by people in
your industry this can help you to
understand and create strategies for the
content that the users are searching
across the internet
and the last tool
in our today's list is
keyword tool dot io keyword two dot io
has free as well as paid versions
keyword to load io helps to get keyword
ideas from various sources like google
youtube
bing
amazon
ebay
instagram twitter
pinterest etc
we will definitely understand how to use
these tools in the upcoming part of the
video
to make use of these tools it is
necessary to understand
how to perform a keyword research
as we have already seen why keyword
research is important
let's now see how to perform keyword
research
here are the top 5 ways to perform
keyword research to perform keyword
research it is important to understand
the domain
and who the audience is
understanding the correct audience will
help you to get more correct keyword
during the research
for example if you are performing
keyword research for healthcare website
the audience would be a patient
or anyone who wants to know about health
center or a disease so with this tip
let's try our hands on the first keyword
research technique
which is
keyword discovery
to get a list of keywords
use keyword research tools like google
keyword planner
rfs etc now all you need to do is go to
the keyword research tool and search for
the required keyword idea here sugar
free ice cream is what i have searched
for now if you see at the bottom you
will see
the relevant keywords for sugar free ice
cream with their average monthly
searches
change
year on year change
competition
ads impression share
bidding
with high and low etc so let me bring it
to you notice that from all the keywords
in the list not every keyword will be
important
or will be useful for your industry so
while choosing a keyword please be
careful so always choose a keyword with
a good search volume higher search
volumes are always good
so by choosing keyword make sure that
monthly search volume
is at least between
1k to 10k or above so with monthly
search volumes you can see another
metric which is competition
it is a helpful metric during a keyword
research
each keyword will either have a high
competition a low competition or a
medium competition
this metric helps the user to understand
the keyword difficulty or how hard it is
to rank for your website for this
particular keyword
a keyword with high competition have
more number of bidders high competition
keywords are mostly taken up by the
advertisers who are willing to put up
their ad campaigns
now talking about how to choose keywords
for organic rankings dear learners
competition metrics will also be helpful
here you will understand this in the
upcoming part of the video we have
already learned about long tail keywords
and short tail keywords so now with the
help of keyword type and various metrics
learned earlier
let's understand how to choose keywords
to get organic rankings
suppose
you have a new business
so initially it will be difficult to get
relevant audience for your site
in such a situation try getting a long
tail keyword with good search volume and
low competition
long tail keywords are helpful in
getting more accurate results if the
keyword is long tail
the chances of ranking it higher in the
search engine result pages
increases
however we are also choosing low
competition which suggests that
competition for keyword is low and the
chosen keyword can take a strong
position in the search results this can
help you to get more of the relevant
audience
once you started getting more and more
traffic you can experiment with short
tail keywords with low medium and high
competition
now considering your business has a very
strong hold over a market in such a
situation you can simply choose long
tail keywords with good search volume
and medium or high competition this will
help you to attract audiences
organically all through paid campaigns
next we will see
search for trending keywords to get an
instant spike in the traffic trending
keywords are the best ones to be
targeted
all you need to do is keep an eye on
what's the recent news or the trending
topic in your industry now create the
content targeting those keywords for
your website
for this you can make use of google
trends which will help you to identify
the trending keywords
also you can choose the search platforms
like web search youtube search etc or
select the geographical location as per
your requirement well if you have great
content then the next strategy will be
hundred percent effective for your
business
which is competitor keyword research
it is said that don't work hard
work smart
so let's try to do some smart work here
gather the list of competitors who are
doing well in your industry
now keep an eye on the keywords that
they are using to represent their
products and services
if those keywords benefit your
competitors
then
they will definitely prove fruitful for
your business as well
to find competitor keywords you can use
various competitor research tools
check the video on top 10 free seo tools
to get the best knowledge about
competitor research tools you can get
the link from the description box below
the strategy of using competitor
keywords works best for you as well as
strong businesses
next let me put a light on another
important keyword research strategy
which is
to identify search terms people are
looking for this is the best and
quickest way to attract audiences for
example i have an ice cream business
nowadays people are more health
conscious so there is a possibility that
a person suffering from diabetes is
likely to search
for sugar-free ice creams near me or how
to make a sugar free ice cream
here i get one of the important keywords
with respect to my ice cream business
again if i say i have a tourism business
then i will look for the keywords around
travel and tourism now suppose a person
is looking for best location to spend
holidays
here i will get an important keyword to
highlight my tourism business
in a travel blog website
so now the question arises how to get
these keywords dear learners to get such
keyword ideas just go to google.com and
use auto suggest features from google
all you need to do is simply type
whatever query you require
and you will get a list of
recommendation below recommendations are
the easiest way to understand
what the audience is actually looking
for
now all you need to do is pin down all
these keywords and choose the relevant
one for your domain this strategy is
completely fair with new or any business
which has hole over a market
if you are interested in creating new
content
then try checking answer the public tool
which will give you the keyword ideas in
your industry that audience are actually
searching next we have is reverse
keyword mining
with this strategy we will try to dig
the keywords for which your website
appears in the search results
but may not get clicked
let's see how it is done
check the performance reports in the
google search console here you will get
list of keywords for which your site
appears it is possible that your site
may not have accurate content and so may
not get clicks and thereby gaining no
traffic from that keyword however these
keyword ideas are the indications that
search engines somewhere finds your
content relevant to these keywords and
that is the reason your website is
getting several impressions for that
keyword
you can choose keywords and create
accurate content which will thereby
result in gaining a great audience for
your website
now that you are aware of how to do
keyword research let's try to understand
how to use keyword research tools and
implement the above strategies for
various scenarios
so we are going to demonstrate
few keyword research tools here
the number one is keyword planner
next is google trends and next we have
is sem rush
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more so now first we
will start with keyword planner
let's go to keyword planner
so here we are in the keyword planner
for those who are new to keyword planner
go to tools and settings and just click
on keyword planner
and there you come up with the keyword
planner tool
now let's consider that you have a
blogging site
and you are on a way to create a very
amazing and creative content on how to
make a sugar free ice cream
so if you see here keyword planner works
in both ways
you can directly input your keyword and
get the list of keywords
or get the list of relevant keywords or
you can just add a
csv file and you can get the search
volume for already researched keywords
so now here i'll just input
how to make
a
sugar
free
ice cream
and just hit enter you can add your
number of keywords to check so for now
i'm just adding one
and just click on get results
over here
you can see a large number of results
now you can see here none of the keyword
is having monthly search volume in
between 1k to 10k
so let's find another relevant keyword
so suppose we
choose here sugar free ice cream
and click on get results
so now here we got our main keyword as
sugar free ice cream which has 1k to 10k
of monthly searches
and yes definitely the competition is
high means there are a lot of
competitors and it is somewhat uh
difficult to rank with this keyword
but
we can take a trial for here to choose
this keyword as a main title for our
blog
again we have here sugar free ice cream
near me
so again this is somewhat location based
query so someone who is looking for the
ice cream centers near
them so there is a possibility that
those audiences will be adding this
query to get the appropriate results
but this won't be accurate for our
blogging site
to make a sugar free ice cream
so
let's check what is there in the list
okay every
keyword is high has a high competition
so let's choose here sugar free ice
cream for our blog followed by some
other secondary keywords like sugar free
ice cream making or
how to make sugar free ice cream or low
sugar ice cream as their secondary
keywords
also there is a setting
to get the relevant keyword ideas as per
the location so here it is india so you
can choose a location
as per any country say this is china
you can choose for china as well
like here if you added china
there's a
okay so you will get the relevant result
as per china and india if you are not
selecting any of the country
then
we will be targeting all the countries
in the world
for that particular keyword
now let's take another example
to
find
now let's search for
best
jogging shoes
so let's see all the relevant ideas what
the planner suggests
so yes we got here best jogging shoes
maybe most of the audiences adding this
query to get the results so the
competition is quite high
in this case we can we can just select
the best jogging shoes and if you want
more specific then we can go with best
jogging shoes for men or women also i
would like to bring it to your notice
that please remember to choose the
relevant keywords as per your
requirement
there will be lots of results which
won't be
so relevant to your topic or to your
content
so make sure you're choosing the correct
keyword as per your content
after taking this keyword idea as best
jogging shoes you can just create a very
good content
either it may be a blog or an article
or a video
or a website content or text for the
website or anything you want to create
for best jogging shoes and make sure
that you are adding the this keyword
inside your
content
to make it more accurate for the search
engines
now next we move towards our another
keyword research tool which is google
trends
so go to google.com and search for
google
trends
okay
so we are here
so
just to remind you google trend will
provide us with all the trending topics
or trending search terms
which can lead to a better ranking or
instant spike in your traffic
so suppose you're looking for the latest
trend in your industry
in that case
let's take again take an example of a
sugar free ice cream so i'll add here
sugar
pre
ice cream okay i i just got the term in
the recommendations
it is from the food industry so just to
bring it to your notice from here we can
select the worldwide or any country
whatever we want to select
or check for this search query
then again we have a data for whatever
time duration we want the data for that
particular search query
here we have a number of categories like
food industry entertainment etc etc
if you want to select you can just
choose it for now i'm not choosing here
anything and of course the web search
the email search
news search google and youtube search so
let's see
let's select here youtube search
and let's let's select here worldwide
so here we can get the insights
uh the interest over the time
so if you see here from
june 12th
to 19 june there was a certain drop in
this keyword people were not searching
this keyword and again from 19 to 25
there is an increase in this keyword
like people are more searching for this
keyword
again you can see here the data like
interest by region so it is mostly
search
in australia
then followed by canada pakistan
united states united kingdom etc
and it also suggests you other related
queries here
now suppose
uh we want to compare it to
another search term say
ice cream
maker let's see
the comparison between these two
search queries
okay
so if you can see here
from
july
2021
this keyword
ice cream maker is showing
a consistent small growth
whereas
the sugar free ice cream is
very much consistent there is not growth
or not much drop both the graphs are
showing us these insights
so i hope you got a good knowledge about
google trends
how to use google trends
so let's see how to get some of the
competitor keywords
so for this we will go to sem rush
so here we are
to our sem rush tool so
semrush is a all-in-one platform which
satisfies all the basic needs of search
engine optimization practices we get a
lot of like keyword research tool is
there competitive analysis tools is
there
then we can identify the backlinks the
content gap the backlink gaps
and a lot of like an organic traffic for
your website and many more
so please do check out uh sem rush
you can find the link in the description
box below
and also it has a free as well as paid
version some of the searches are free
after which
you can check on with the paid plans
also so we highly recommend you to take
a walk through through this tool
now let's go to
the keyword gap
from here you can uh get the ideas about
you
and your competitor
so suppose
i'm adding here
okay so let's select the
country region here
and we are doing for
we were using for the ice cream so let's
let's take
a mole
company
which is a mole.com
okay
dot com
and uh
another
can be
mother
theory
ice cream
it's www.motherdairy.com
so
www.motherdairy.com
okay
so let's do the check for india only
let's not put it for usa
compare
okay so here you can see
a lot of
opportunities
keyword overlap
there are almost 1.7 k like 1700 shared
keywords
can see the search volumes as well
and all the related data for both the
companies their products
and comparison
so here i am using a free plan for sem
rush
so i won't be able to show the complete
report here
but yes definitely we can export the all
the related data from uh
the competitor analysis
let's check for mobile
yes you can see here the
large difference between the overlap
keywords
you can also get the data for the
organic keywords paid keywords
paid keywords are mainly those keywords
which are used for advertising purposes
you can change the date here
and all the data to get whatever kind of
results or data or insights you want
i hope now you have mastered the keyword
research techniques let us now see how
keyword research is important as a job
role
now coming to the job opportunities
keyword research is the most important
part of any role in search engine
optimization or digital marketing the
job descriptions in seo and digital
marketing are likely to include keyword
research under the job requirements like
performing keyword research including
discovery and expansion of keyword
opportunities
or
perform keyword research in coordination
with client business objectives to
optimize existing content and discover
new opportunities
or to conduct keyword research using
various tools
following is the basic template for the
job description for seo analyst
here you can see the first job
responsibility is to perform keyword
research using various keyword research
tools like keyword planner
so this itself suggests that how keyword
research is very much important in
search engine optimization or digital
marketing jobs
here are some of the companies which are
hiring for seo profiles
so the companies includes microsoft
disney siemens udemy deloitte etc
however
every online business requires seo
strategies to grow and so the companies
hiring for seo profiles are not
restricted to these five companies
so moving ahead
let's see what the future of keyword
research holds
performing keyword research in a smart
way can bring you all the golden traffic
for your website
gaining a relevant audience is always
fruitful for any business
however it is recommended not to stay
limited to keyword research
you also need to keep an eye on how
keywords are actually performing are
they really driving the relevant traffic
if not then recheck the content and
align keywords identify the gaps and
update the content accordingly
so this is it for today's session if you
like this video consider subscribing to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply learn
we will definitely come up with another
interesting topic on seo till then
thanks for watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here you